das ist wirklich eine wissenschaftliche
sensation zum ersten mal wurde in die
quelle der rätselhaften geister teilchen
entdeckt woher sie stammen konnte bisher
nicht herausgefunden werden sie sind
nämlich überhaupt nur sehr schwer zu
finden obwohl sie massenhaft im weltall
vorkommen die neutrinos sind geister
teilchen doch eine gigantische mess
station in der antarktis hat es jetzt
geschafft und damit wurde ein
jahrhundert rätsel der physik gelöst
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
da gestern prasselten auf whatsapp die
nachrichten nur so rein eine neue
wissenschaft sensation wurde verkündet
die entdeckung der quelle der neutrinos
der geister teilchen nicht so unrecht
werden sie so bezeichnet ihre masse ist
äußerst gering für die erkenntnis dass
überhaupt eine haben bekamen das
entsprechende forschungsteam 2015 den
nobelpreis für sich die geister teilchen
gehen nur wirklich selten eine
wechselwirkung mit der materie wie wir
sie kennen ein weil sie eben nicht
interagieren rasen sie ungestört durch
sein
das macht es extrem schwierig
herauszufinden woher sie kommen doch das
hat der ice cube in der antarktis jetzt
herausgefunden das observatorium namens
ice cube das zur amerikanische amundsen
scott forschungsstation am südpol gehört
ist wohl eines der spannendsten
experimente weltweit 5160 sensoren
wurden dafür tief in den antarktischen
untergrund versenkt und zwar bis zu 2,5
kilometer tief zusammen bilden sie ein
riesiges dreidimensionales detektor feld
echter wahnsinn und hier wird die
sogenannte tschernjakow strahlung
erforscht damit ist das leuchten gemeint
dass durch die kollision die extrem
seltenen kollisionen von neutrinos mit
den wassermolekülen das einst entstehen
und das passiert nicht oft doch wenn es
passiert dann richtig pro sekunde
prallen zwischen 60 und 100 milliarden
neutrinos auf jeden quadratzentimeter
der erde ein
sie stammen von gigantischen ereignissen
welt halt wie den supernova explosionen
oder gammastrahlen ausbrüchen und ihre
unfassbare beschleunigung kann man sich
eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen in
untersuchungen wurden tatsächlich
neutrinos mit einer energie von 980 tera
elektronenvolt dv analysiert zum
vergleich im lhc also dem large hadron
collider des genfer
kernforschungszentrums cern sind
protonen mit gerade mal 13 tera
elektronenvolt am start und noch einen
ziemlich krasse landen und ins
mittlerweile werden mit hilfe des ice
cube auf sat 1 auch schon teilchen im
bereich von peter elektronenvolt
gemessen also mehr als 1000 tera
elektronenvolt neutrinos ich habe nie
nebensatz zu allen anderen teilchen eine
unsere eigenschaft sie interagieren kaum
oder selben mit materials haben wir
schon gehört daraus ergibt sich aber
auch dass sie nicht abgelenkt werden sie
fliegen direkt von der stromquelle
geradeaus trübsal und deshalb kann man
nur bei ihnen herausfinden woher sie
stammen und damit woher vorher ihre
unglaublichen energien stammen bisher
waren allerdings keine muster zu
erkennen sie kamen aus allen richtungen
mit schwachen und hohen energien ein
muster war eben einfach nicht zu
erkennen bis zum 22
september 2017 damals entdeckte der nasa
gammastrahlen die fermi eine riesige
gamma strand quelle in der galaxie txs
05 06 06 damals wurde der satellit
aufgrund der messungen des ice cubes auf
diese galaxie ausgerichtet weil dort
eben eine strahlenquelle vermutet wurde
wie geht vom schwarzen loch im zentrum
aus das einen seiner jets direkt auf uns
ausgerichtet hat es ist ein basar ein
aktives super massereiches schwarzes
loch das eine extrem heiße
akkretionsscheibe um sich kreisen lässt
und nach oben und unten jets ausspuckt
einer trifft uns und wir können die
strahlung messen
zum einen die gammastrahlung und zum
anderen eben einige wenige neutrinos und
dann soll ich es wurde vorher im ice
cube gefunden
zum einen dieses hoch energetische
neutrino und zu anderen auch welche mit
schwächerer energie den alten daten des
ice cubes aus den jahren 2013 und 14
stammten damit hat der ice cube eine
wichtige erkenntnis gewonnen
solche blase sind die quelle von
riesigen teilchen eruptionen und der
ursprung von neutrinos jetzt wird dort
weiter geforscht die forschungsgruppen
suchen jetzt neutrinos die aus
bestimmten richtungen stammen und geben
deren daten an teleskope und satelliten
rund um den globus weiter damit sie
weitere quellen ausmachen es bleibt also
spannend bei der suche nach
strahlenquellen im weltall wenn er keine
videos sagte und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei
whatsapp dann umgeht er die kaputte abo
boxee auf youtube und verpasst kein
video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
immer und zwar vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video täglichen garantiert
einfach dafür hier draufklicken und am
besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks
um social media abonnieren da gibt es
das neueste aus der social media welt
darf
hier klicken aber nicht die genau glocke
vergessen wie geht es weiter mit dafür
auch dort klicken neutrinos das rätsel
der geister teilchen wird es jetzt
gelöst bis dann bleib dran